spoiler alert I don't watch trailers
just putting that out there huh
[Applause]
superhero team ups there's so many we
have a major one in infinity war coming
out Justice League was just last year
what is happening I remember all the way
back in 2000 when we first got x-men and
I was like yeah it's set it off cuz it
was coming on the heels of an animated
series that was so popular and the kids
that watch the TV shows they showed up
for that movie it really was a great
lead into all of these superhero movies
that we've seen ever since again we did
have Justice League last year but I if
I'm gonna see the DC EU I like it on the
small screen there's a thing I like to
call the flare over that slash arrow
universe each one of those individual
shows has teens and actually within
Avengers
there's team-ups yeah no there is
because Civil War busted everybody apart
yeah it's been a full decade to get to
this point how do we get here we got
here after 18 other movies 18 pounds of
popcorn consumed many 10 years hundreds
of characters to get to the same point
that the DC you literally put the pedal
to the metal and rush through to get
through in five years and finally of
skipping high school and then trying to
take the SAT anyway yeah then when it
doesn't work out you're like man I guess
I should have gone to a class with
Marvel it's been 18 movies if you had a
friend I had never seen any of them
which one would you say like these are
the ones you should watch got it watch
the team-up movies yeah Avengers age of
Ultron and then Civil War the throne
guardians space stuff the story I mean
just watches the whole thing like this
is why I hate I hate the idea this
question because I researched your world
of watching there's no Jeff Goldblum and
there's no Black Panther and so I'm a
completionist and I say watch them all
check this out
I accidentally hid an infinity stone in
my belly oh there it is yes
my mom said not to do that let's talk
about the stones in general like the
Russo brothers the directors of this and
Civil War have said this is a reverse
kind of heist movie like they have the
treasure they're trying to keep someone
from robbing it in Justice League it was
like also a similar thing like trying to
gather up these squares cubed things
transformers thank you baby it's
literally just functionally a boss that
you could sit on and use it as an
ottoman even I couldn't possibly listen
to one more person say the word box in
Justice League I was like not compelling
let's talk more about jewels okay
that's why I love these Infinity stones
let's pull them up those so we have
reality yes we obviously know we saw
that one in Thor the dark world he loves
that one the space one last scene that
was the tesseract Loki oh that guy
yeah the soul stone is the big mystery
nobody knows where it's at the time
Doctor Strange the Nova Corps back from
guardians the galaxy had the power there
is the soul stone the logical place for
its that it's in Wakanda right don't
know if it's right that they put this
also in Wakanda like there's just some
comedy there in that one but whatever it
was been played James Brown in a
different universe so I'm okay with him
they knew that Thanos was gonna be our
big villain his reason for existence is
to assemble these stones into his
Infinity Gauntlet and sort of smash his
will through the universe here's what's
interesting about all these movies so
many of these dudes obsessed with
jewelry yeah right it really has the
power there was a team up to go find the
one ring as well let's be honest when
there's big villains you need a team
here's a big bad that didn't work very
well
apocalypse mmm less satisfying than the
actual supposed apocalypse on December
21st of 2012 I'm so excited for the
Avengers but if we were gonna give them
their knock I mean besides Loki Thanos
is the first one that I believe again my
small screen brethren have better
villains Wilson Fisk
from the daredevil franchise kilgrave
from Jessica Jones zoom
/and friends those are some pretty good
millage that's the one thing that with
the movies I do have Lacroix with that
they get rid of their villains so fast
yeah I mean we'll be right before this
though I think if we're gonna say
besides Thanos that got a villain right
kill monger I think it's probably the
best villain since Loki he was the
villain but he wasn't necessarily wrong
no that's right that's the best conflict
right a conflict of ideologies and then
they were just like watch the Sun set
and then die but it was such a pretty
sunset it was on that note I think I
should have said this earlier but
spoiler alert
I don't like spoilers to the point that
I don't watch trailers just putting that
out there huh I don't watch any kind now
we have to reenact the entire train oh
look it's a shot of the city and then
hold on it's like my dad is super me let
me tell you his whole plan get this
menace you do that thing that means that
you only have theories that have not
come from watching this really yes what
are your pure wild hare theories for
this one
the Santos is gonna be like if it's like
any other Marvel movie he's gonna die in
the end
not this one we got 60 people on these
call sheets or something like that they
got plenty to go around and you know
some of those we wouldn't miss okay yeah
listen I wrote I've got a beautiful
cartoon I can get my illustrious actor
friend to help me out with a yellow suit
against type so I'll be the woman so you
think you know who's gonna die
speak on it sis well it's on the low but
it's gonna be Hawkeye that's not secret
but it's true like I think that vision
yeah Thanos is gonna be the Clearasil of
that blemish and just like my bets
probably for Iron Man Captain America I
went on the internet and did a deep dive
cuz I'm an obsessive there's a lot of
ink out there on who's gonna die and I
love that everybody thinks it can be
anyone because that is what makes this
movie I think the one that we're gonna
love hands off my Black Widow she's been
through a lot
she has assets I'm not going to say that
she does it but she's bringing a gun
- a planet fight have you seen what that
woman can do with her inner thighs so
what is the interaction in this
cavalcade of characters that you are
looking forward to the most
you can't put star-lord and Iron Man in
the same scene and expect them to get
along I mean the trailer already
basically told us that right they
weren't gonna get along Doctor Strange
let's be honest I don't know how well
he's gonna do with this whole massive
mega team it just doesn't look like he
plays well with others people that are
smarter to kind of just act like that
all the time is that what's wrong with
you we got to go to trivia you guys were
my friends and now you are my enemies
now are you guys this is our very own
Civil War buddy yes do it which Infinity
stones red I think I know this you guys
ought to go when down all right we're
ready
oh it's yes all right next question
which villain has never appeared in a
live-action superhero franchise this
one's a little tough not if you know
your stuff okay which of these actors
has been in the most comic book movies
pretty much duh I think yeah this is an
easy one what what though what he was in
danger future pass and he was in the
adventure of the lie detector also
created which superhero I got this one
Festus did yeah professor Marsden and
the Wonder Woman I'm sorry I'm too busy
dancing yeah XS yeah what is the name of
Wolverine son a tough one all right knew
it knew it from the comics
that question all right who owned the
super pet and super cute dog ms lion I
feel like I don't understand half the
nouns in this sentence jacqueline wins
no curses guys we can talk about movies
all day long oh you won't this time
around yeah because coming out yes and
you should totally pick up your tickets
at finding go calm or on the mobile app
we'll see you really soon
[Music]